ce que vous allez voir c'est les
dizaines et dizaines de patients en
réanimation c'est les annonces mortuaire
dans le journal l'alsace
on a actuellement cinq pages dénonce
mortuaire voilà c'est ça l'art est les
vieux c'est des personnages et des
personnes âgées meurent les personnes
âgées sont en rien et en rien on a
malheureusement des perchaudes des
personnes jeunes des moins de 60 ans
déjà en pleine santé qui sont frappés
par le vieux sol pourquoi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de patients donc fatalement par
les lois statistiques si on dire je ne
sais pas combien de proville 3 pour
mille comme il ya cinquante mille cent
mille personnes touchées eh bien il ya
200 300 patients graves dont des jeunes
qui vont peut-être nous vivre du corps
d'un donc oui la seule arme que nous
avons actuellement confinement mesures
barrières mais sur barrières lavage des
mains port du masque si vous en avez
mais confinement restez à distance les
uns des autres c'est ça va être long ça
va être pénible mais ces voix là il faut
qu'on s'applique vraiment ça c'est un
acte de solidarité par rapport à nos
concitoyens vos concitoyens tous les
canadiens que ce que je dis aux
canadiens vous dit pas encore mais ne
faites pas l'erreur qu'on a fait c'est
les deux ce qui va marcher c'est le
confinement et les mesures barrières